the Tesla Model Y and Tesla Model 3 have
some amazing features today we're
talking about 10 hidden features that
you're going to absolutely love one
hidden feature that I bet you didn't
know is that you can download a free app
called Tessie with this app you can
basically open up your front or your
boot completely via your mobile phone so
you can use Siri to open your boot or
your front when your hands are
completely full so for example open boot
while we're on the topic of the boot we
can obviously reduce the actual boot
opening height so if we simply pull the
boot down press and hold our boot Button
for three seconds until it beeps
that's going to be our new set boot
height so now we can close our boot wait
for it to fully close and then the next
time we reopen it it's only going to
open that SEC maximum height once again
if we want to push it back up all the
way just simply push it up press and
hold the button until it beeps again now
let's say you're charging your vehicle
and for some reason the Chargers stuck
in the charge port well in here
underneath the charge port there's
actually a secret latch that you can
pull hard and automatically release that
charge port so if your vehicle does get
stuck in a charger you can get out of it
by simply pulling the latch rather than
freaking out if you're about to hand
over your Tesla to a valet driver for
instance you can basically limit your
vehicle's performance and ability if you
come up to the top where your user is
profiled in you can change across to
valet mode which is going to lock your
vehicle into valet mode and then if they
try to actually access out of it it's
going to request a four digit PIN for
them to be able to actually use this car
to its full capabilities most people
believe you have to go out and purchase
premium connectivity now premium
connectivity obviously isn't free but
you're already paying for your mobile
service so you might as well go ahead
and hotspot your phone directly to your
Tesla in that way you can basically
understand and use your Spotify your
Netflix and anything else that requires
internet at any point in time a little
known feature is a simple fact that you
can actually share your Apple Maps or
your Google Maps directly with your
Tesla instead of going in and typing in
your location you can simply plug in
what you're looking for swipe across the
share button and then we'll come all the
way across until you find Tesla in a few
seconds it'll automatically transition
that right across to your Tesla screen
one of the great things about the Tesla
is the minimal interior but that also
means you don't have a physical parking
brake or even a parking brake button
well in actual fact you do have a
parking brake button if you simply press
and hold the park button for three
seconds it will engage the emergency
handbrake alternatively if you don't
want to press the parking button or for
whatever reason it's broken you can come
across the little vehicle jump across
the safety swipe down and you'll see
your emergency parking brake button now
something that is somewhat annoying is
the fact we've just crossed a new speed
limit and our speed hasn't gone up
typically you'd have to scroll the wheel
up rapidly to increase the speed but
instead you can simply press and hold
the lever down to automatically adjust
to the latest steering speed now Teslas
also make a variety of noises Chimes and
charms if you don't like that you can
simply press on the little car vehicle
down the bottom come across the safety
scroll all the way down to the bottom
and tap Joe mode so what Joe mode
basically does is it reduces the volume
of your car's chimes for quieter and
more child-friendly experience basically
for Joe's kids who requested this
feature on Twitter and Tesla made it
happen via a software update last but
not least is a very simple and very
convenient software update if you turn
on your indicators and you're going
either left or right the blind spot
camera comes up but what we didn't have
before is the ability to move the blind
spot camera to three positions on the
actual screen so if you don't like the
position and your hand is covering part
of the screen you can actually move it
across to the most ideal location for
you anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you check out the playlist inside
of me for more great Tesla content if
you love the video make sure you smash
that subscribe button down below but
like always I'll see you next Monday